はい それが浄論で 阿部公に対してブッダは何書いてるのか
おっしゃってるのかと
今前喋ったのは宗教 世間一般的に
だから宗教は世間 世間
世間 世界は幻覚だよ 嘘だよと言ってますけど
お釈迦様はそんなこと言ってるのか
仏教の現世は幻覚だと説かれているのでしょうかということ
はい それからもう一番最初
最後のお話に入ります
それが終わったら最初の話に入ります
あべこべできます 一切回向ということは
まあまあ皆様も把握できてるでしょう
般若心経も大乗経典ではよく出てくる謳い文句ですね
無責任で無条件な言葉をブッダは語らないんです
何のことなく 一切回向や
そんなことはお釈迦様は言うはずもないんです
ブッダの言葉じゃなくて
頭の悪い無知な人の言葉なんです
ただ 生命は認識情報 いわゆる対象をそのまま認識しないで
捏造して認識するのだと説くんです
お釈迦様はもうちょっとすごい理性的なこと
世の中は存在しないんだ
世の中空だよとは言わないんです
我々に入る情報をそのまま
その事実を知ることしないで
捏造して知ったことにするんだと
この捏造することで 本物は知らなくなっているんだよと
だから問題は捏造すること
このパパンチャナということなんですね
だから まあこれは何々と私が言っても
それはちょっと違いますよとブッダも言います
それちょっと違いますよというのは
あんた見てるのは幻だよ
幻覚だよということ意味ではなくて
あなたデータを捏造したんだよと
だから何回も言いますから
この私はこのパパンチャという言葉にはもう正しい日本語で戯論という言葉があるんです
で 私はどうせ正しいこと喋れませんから
わざとその言葉を使わないで
捏造という単語を使っているんです
捏造という言葉が勉強してください
今日から説明します 今から捏造するためにはデータが必要なんです
何もないところで何か捏造することはできないんです
捏造の意味はデータを誤魔化すんです
何のためかというと 自分のためなんです
例えば研究する人は怠けてもう
でもしかしすごい良い研究家だとみんなに褒めてもらって
合格してもらって 金も借りたいんです
そうすると人のデータをいろいろパクったりと so んたりして
それをあれやこれやと捏造して
何かもうこういう証拠を見つかりました
あの証拠を見つかりましたとか
いい加減なでたらめなことを言って書いて論文研究出すんですよ
だからデータがあるんだけど
それは捏造するんです
捏造するためにはないものを言うんです
例えば 私は考古学やったこともないし
考古学の世界ではもう何も知らない
考古学の学生さえも 私は考古学知っている人として認めない
それで私が何か文章を書いたっても
もう考古学です 絶対相手にしないんです
で 例えば縄文時代はこうこうでありましたか
ああでありましたとか言ったって
あんた何言ってるのかと
ということは 私に捏造することはできないんです
しかし 縄文時代についてちょこちょこっと研究しようとする人には
それできるんです だから捏造するためにはデータが必要
捏造する人は それ自分のために
自分の都合のためにやっているんです
そういうわけで すべての生命が捏造しているんだという場合は
そのその生命がデータを自分の都合に乗って
こう都合に合わせて書き換えているという話なんです
だから それは一切回向みたいな回向みたいなね
いとも簡単に どんな馬鹿にも言えることじゃないんです
ヒンドゥー教でもすべては幻
幻覚だとか 勝手に言いなさいよ
ちゃんと論理的に説明して言わなくちゃいけないんです
これだから これだから
これがこうなってるんだよと
いっぱいそういう言葉ありますよ
あの あまりこの大乗仏教は否定的じゃないんで
一切回向といったっても
それは一つの宗派だけで
他の宗派がとことん仏教と同じく
この現世を正当化するんです
すべての人々は本覚であると
いわゆる生まれつきもう悟ってるんだと
ブッダが言おうと みんなもうヒンドゥー教と同じこと言ってるんです
お寺のお坊さんがあんたも本格的な如来
ブッダでいたっても何のこともないんですけどね
自分にとってはもうただ試験は落第するわ
仕事を失敗するわ 奥さんと喧嘩するわ
友達と喧嘩する お坊さん何一つ言ってないんです
それでよ 寺の坊さん あなたは如来そのものやと言われたってても
そんないい加減なことっていうのは
無責任なことをね いくらでも言えますよ
だから妄想を喋るんだから
誰にでもその資格はありますよ
妄想を喋る資格は しかし
本当のことを喋るということは
稀な人間にしかできないんです
そういうわけで このお釈迦様が世界は幻だ
あれやこれやとは言わない
一切懐柔とも教え言わない
その代わりに我々の認識システムはこうなっているんだよと
それを調べればわかることなんですね
外の世界さえも存在しないではないのです
ですから 外の世界は存在しませんとお釈迦様は言いません
存在するんだそうともあまり言わないんです
ちょっとあなた方はねつ造してるんだからね
だから話になりませんよ
外の世界について話してますよ
それでも話してもちょこちょこ理解しないんですね
だから まずこのねつ造することをやめてもらいましょうと
これはならないんだと
知性のある人間として
何でもかんでもねつ造するの
それやってる限りは あなたに私の話はわからないんだよということで
みんなにこの先にねつ造することだけ何とかしてくださいと
そうすると 私が当たり前のことを言っているのもよくわかりますよと
事実を語っているんだから
生命の六感も外の情報対象
絶えず生滅変化してゆく流れなのです
これがブッダの教えなんですね
これをねつ造しないと
ねつ造 ねつ造 ねつ造しない人にわかるものなんです
生命の六感 我々には六感があります
目 耳 鼻 舌 体と心という
そこでものを知っているんです
自分がいるんだぞと この六感が感覚があるんだから知っているんです
感覚がなければ自分がいるということも何もないんです
だから この感覚がある
その感覚にデータが対象触れるんですね
触れると知るということが起こるんですね
それは瞬間瞬間変化していく流れですよと
その流れも原因により生じ
原因により滅するものですと
したがって あると言える
止まっている実体はないんだよと
だって流れていくんだからあるあると言えないんです
花があるとか牛がいるとか言えないんです
目に見える牛の幻想というのはずっと流れているんです
ずっと流れているんだから
牛さえもずっと流れているんです
私の体さえもずっと流れているものなんです
だからあるあるとは言えないんだよ
実体は成り立たないという意味で空ですが
だからお釈迦様は最初に空という単語を使ったんです
それは実体あるというものはないんだよという意味なんです
存在はない 何もないという意味の空は間違っているんです
だから 般若心経で言う空はもう完全に邪見で邪教で極点
極限的な邪見なんです
そんなことは輪廻もないんだ
出脱もないんだ 悟りもないんだ
もうあの三納三部何もない
あるのは自分だけや どこまでアホかと
何ももないんだったら
ギャーギャーで話を変えてもないでしょう
だからいかに頭がもう変わっているのかということですよ
だから世の中はすごい真剣に信仰していますよ
日本人は宗教に興味ないくせに
般若心経だけはもう特にお守りに使うわ
うちわにも書いてあるわ
呪能にも書いてあるわ
入墨にも書いてあるわ
だからそこまで信仰厚いのは嘘だからなんです
だって嘘は信じちゃダメなんですよ
事実は信じる必要ないんだから
例えば地球が丸いと誰も信じてはいませんよ
だって事実だから だからこの信仰厚いということで
私に貢献したって意味がないんです
あんたこのみんな信仰していることに対して何も言わないの
それは何か意味があるでしょう
意味があるんです 守っている
あまりにも信仰厚くてね
なかなかもう 変わらないといえば
もうこれはもう嘘 嘘に決まってるんです
はい それから天道という話に入ります
この天道っていうのは
あべこべのちょっとま
ちょっとまとめなまとめな言葉なんですね
まあそれは仏教用語あべこべという意味なんです
言葉がわからない方から
この逆さまに物事高いなのに低いと理解する
低いなのに高いと理解する
汚いのに綺麗だと勘違いするということは天道というんですね
年取っているのに若いと思ったりすることとか
天道なんです それからアンクッとネガチャットクネバでロイタスワッグすってなんもない
今日ですね チャタローメディカルサンニャーイバララサチットイバララサディティバララサカメチャタロー
意味はわかります ビクたちよ
概念 天道 心の天道 見解の天道は 4つあります
これから説明します で
お釈迦様の言葉というのは随分短くて
ちょっと意味がありすぎ
概念 天道 心の天道 それから見解
天道という天道の言葉が 3つありまして
この天道はまた 4つありますね
まず天道が起こる 3箇所
1サンニャーイバララサ
何かを見たり聞いたり
嗅いだり 味わったり 触れたり
思い浮かんだりした瞬間で
それは何かという そう
概念瞬時に起こります
それは概念天道なんです
何か見た瞬間で これは何かと知ってるんです
聞いた瞬間で それは何かと知ってるんです
ものすごく早いんですよ
そんな瞬間で知れる知れるんですかね
音が耳に触れた瞬間で
何の音かが知ってるんですよ
この理解力はものすごく早い
この概念はありのままの事実ではなく
天道したものです 天道しているんです
例えば ちょっとキャーっていう声が聞こえた瞬間で
いきなりカラスだとか
子供だとか もう瞬時にもう知ってるんです
この瞬時に知ってることはかっこいいわけじゃないんです
これは天道だよと あんた調べたんですか？と
調べることも何もしないで瞬時に知ることが起こるんですよ
例をね 出します 見た瞬間で花だとわかるように
例えばこちら何かあります
目を開けて見た瞬間に
あっ 花ですと 例えば普通歩く時はな
花だとか人だとかね あ
コンビニだとか知ってるでしょうね
あ 信号だとかね それ普通生きてる時
見るもの聞くもの その瞬間で理解していくでしょ
それが天道なんです 早すぎ
ちょっと調べた方がいいのに
でも瞬間に起こるありのままでない事実
いわゆるねつ造してるんです
それは天道の第1番目のステップなんです 2
番目 ちっといバランス
心にたくさんの概念 層が溜まっている
新しいデータ 情報 対象を明確にそのまま認識できない
それで頭の中でいっぱい考え方が溜まってるでしょ
だから本を読んでも なかなかなかなか入らないんですよ
ものを見ても なかなかその本物が見えないんですね
例えば この有名なタレントさんとか何とか出てきて
何か催し物をやってる場合は
もう行く前から 1ヶ月前からもう興奮しているんです
そういう人々が来ると
大体 3ヶ月とか前とか
半年前からもうチケットを買って予約しなきゃ手に入らないでしょ
それでチケットを手に取った途端
もうその時からもう興奮状態で
だから本当にその人はその催し物に行ったところで
その本人に才能あるかないか
面白く歌ってるかないか
さっぱりわからないでしょうに
ただ顔を見ただけでキャーと泣いて喚いたりして
踊ったりふざけたりして
何も楽しみもなく帰りますけど
歌も聞いてないし 踊りも見てないし
だからテレビで見て見て見て見て
その夢でいるんですね
あ 本物を見たとかね 本物を見たならば
なんだどったことないとわかるはずなんですよ
私はそういう人に会ったりした時には言いたくたまらんですよ
あんたよくもテレビでかっこよく映るもんだなと
映んないと全くだらしないでしょうと
不思議なんですよ 生で見ると何のこともないんですよ
皆さんはもっとかっこよく私に見えますけど
あの連中っていうのは
あれ カメラで映って平らに紙になったらかっこよくなるんですよ
次元ではかっこ悪いんです
だから私も面白くてもうカメラを盗んでみたり
いろいろそういうとこ行ったらね
みんなと仲良くしてね
あの芸術をやってる人といろいろ見ると
まあ結構かっこよく平らになっちゃう
男の背もいたっていうのは平ら
紙でしょ それがなんかかっこよく見えるんです
本物を見たら 何よ これやと
笑い この間ゴールデンウィーク来たの
女二人もね なんでだらしない
もう服装はだらだらでもう髪型はいい加減で
でも写真で見るとえらいかっこいいんですね
私はよりはるかに やっぱり
あの なんていうか 平らに過ごした方がかっこよく見えるんですよ
だけど そういう人々はまあ
ちゃんと面接してね 決めて
まあまあタレントさんになるということなんです
だからこちらで言いたいのは
我々は実際頭の中にいっぱい概念が溜まってるんだから
はっきり見ない聞かないんです
自分も歌って歌って覚えている歌ならば
本物の歌手が来て歌って歌うと聞かないで一緒に歌うんです
その時自分の世界に入っちゃうんですよ
あの枯れた声やらあれもうもうもう調子が狂っていて
音程が間違って ということで
それが 2番目の天道というんですね
2番目の天道じゃなくて
我々は天道する 2番  2番目の場所
例えばダイヤを見るとしましょう
何か光るものだとまず知るんです
まずダイヤがあるとしますよね
なんか光ってるものや
それが第 1 の天道なんです
それから次 ダイヤだと知るんです
あ これはダイヤでしょう
と ダイヤだと判断するためには
いろいろ概念が必要でしょ
頭の中に これは頭の中を回転させてダイヤだと認定するんです
それは 2番目の2番目の天道なんです
チッテーパラーサっていうんでパーリ語
で  3番目ディッテーパラーサ
これはちょっと難しい
過去の経験 思考 知識 妄想
好みなどを駆使して様々な見解を作る
人生観 世界観 道徳観などを作る
それで世の中できている我々はいろんな経験があったりして
もういろんなことを妄想したりして
人生について語る 世界の状況について語る
人間について語る いろんな哲学者がありあふれているんですね
だから 何かについて語るために
人生観を持つために 何か哲学を持つためには
たくさん考えなくちゃいけないんです
頭の中に たくさんデータが必要なんです
それで判断するんですね
判断するといえば ほとんど自分の主観と妄想と好みが入っちゃうんです
だから 例えばあの経済的なことを言いましょう
で 世界経済は自由であるべきだと徹底的に言っている人がいる
自分の好みなんです では
そうじゃなくて 日本の経済状況
農民たち 日本の産業を守る
守らなくちゃいけない
だから何でもかんでも規制緩和で困りますよという場合は
それまた好みなんです
例えば鯨を獲っている人々は
鯨を殺すなかれという世間で言っていることはとんでもない迷惑やテロ行為だと
と反対する それはそちらの都合で
好みで言っていることなんですね
事実とどうか また違います
だから鯨殺すのを反対する側が
この連中は嘘までついて
結局は禁止していることを殺しているのではないかと
日本は研究 なんとかなんですね
研究捕鯨  調査捕鯨  調査捕鯨
調査のために捕鯨しているのは食うためじゃないんで
全部食べているんです
微塵も調査なんかしない
だからグリーンピースとかなんとかわかりませんですけど
一番凶暴なグループの名前は違いますね
シーシェパード  シーシェパードというグループがね
で そちらから見れば 俺やっている人もテロリストじゃないけど
嘘までついて調査捕鯨だったら調査捕鯨で
そんなに大量に取らなくても
1匹取ってればいくらでも調査できるでしょう
だからどちらが正しいんですかね
シーシェパードの立場で考えてみれば
日本の方がテロリストで
日本の法で生活を立てている人々から見れば
シーシェパードがテロリストで
だから世の中で言ってることは
みんなそうやって あれこれやろ考えて考えて言ってることで
そんなにではなくて 全然当てにならないんです
人いうことっていうのは
知識そのものの天道なのに
それはよく覚えてください
例えば これはダイヤだと思う場合はそのものを見てないんですよ
頭の中でずっと子供の頃から勉強したものは回転させてダイヤだと結論づけるだけで
だから捏造しちゃったんです
頭の中で だからダイヤだという知識
これは日本だという知識は
初めからの捏造したものなんです
それで捏造した知識をダラダラダラダラ並べ替えて
もうダラダラとさらに思考するともっとひどいんです
無数の天道を無作為に合成して作るもので
これものをこれじゃなくて選ばにならないとね
見解というもの 見解っていうのは
知識っていうのは哲学者いう言葉とかね
人間の魂は永遠なりとかね
この世は神の世界であるとか
神を褒め称えるべきであるとか
いろんなことを言ってますね
日本のおじいさん おばあさんだったら
子供たちに天が見てるんだからとかね
それいろいろこと世の中にありますけど
そういうのはまあ天とした概念をいろいろ合成して言ってることなんです
だからなおさら間違いなんです
こういう順番 何かを見る
大事 あ なんか光ってるんだということを知る
それ時点では天動しているので
次になおさら捏造 捏造して
あ これはダイヤだと決めてしまう
それは 2番目なんです
これで3番目に入ります
ダイヤを見て 私は神に愛されているからダイヤをもらったのですなどの見解に達するんです
これ 3番目のステージなの
だから参加商で人間は物事を逆さまにあべこべにするんです 3
段階  1 2 3  1 では間違いは 3分の1です
2 に立ったら 3分の2間違ってます
3段目にステップに行ったら 3 3ですね
完璧にあべこべなんです
まるっきり逆さまになっているんです
こういうステップで我々の思考
逆さまになるんです だから当然仏教はこのあらゆる信仰やらね
世間論やら哲学思考やらね
これはもうもってのほかや
これ成り立ちません だから瞑想して修行して悟りに達すると
第一でそこをなくなるんです
第一の天道が 見解は消えちゃいます
まあ少々二とか一とかも残ってます
だからまた瞑想して 第三
第二 第四ステージまで行かなくちゃいけないんです
はい 次に天道のお話 天道は 4つです
天道に 3ステップでステップで飛びかかるんです
飛びかかった天道は具体的にお釈迦様は別に
あのバラの花を見て これは美味しいものだと思ったっていう
別にそんな大げさな問題じゃないんです
それは困らなくてもいいんです
普通の世間のことだからね
猫を見て ああ これ怖いなと
こちらにこういう人に攻撃されると死ぬかもしれませんと怖くなったって
まあ別にいいや もうね
あんた猫見ないことにしなさいと
時々子供とも今面白く言うんですよ
猫見て こういう人 牛ぐらい大きくなったらえらいやばいんでしょうとかね
やばいんですよ 猫は牛ぐらい大きくなっちゃうと
人間を攻撃して食べるんです
だから まあまあ まあアホな思考なんですけど
別にそれは心配することはないんで
それでも何か問題が起こるわけじゃないんです
だから天道といったっても
何でもかんでも批判するんじゃないんです
危ない やってはいけない天道が 4つあるんです
これだけはやってはいけないんです
さて 目立ちたろう アニチェビッケニッチヤサンニャニッチャンティサンガイパッラスチットイパッラスディッケイパッラス
意味は無常に対して常にある常住という概念
天道 心の天道 見解の天道です
3ステップ すべて無常ですか？いい
無常じゃないんだよ あるんじゃないのか
我々思っているんです
その天道は危ないんです
一切の現象が瞬間に消える無常であるのに
そのように認識できないんです
瞬間にものごと消えるんですけど
なかなか認識できないんです
それ第一 第二 あ 変わってる
あ こんなでも認識するときはあると認識するんです
我々は何か認識すると
花がある 机があるという認識なんです
本当はあるではないんです
微妙に複雑ですよ 例えば机があると思っちゃうでしょう
じゃないんです 机から情報がすーっと絶えず目に流れないと机は見えないんです
だから机もずっと情報を変えないと流れが起きません
だから実際 机がすーっと変わっているんです
ずっと変わっていると
机の当たる光もすーっと変わって目に入っているんです
それは目がずっと変わることで
変化することで 見える見えるということにするんです
だから夢に机があるってことは成り立たないんです
しかし 我々にとっては机がある
例えば光が屈折すると
例えばあの水が半分ぐらい入っているガラスに鉛筆を入れちゃうと曲がっちゃうんでしょう
鉛筆は曲がるわけないんだけど
なんで曲がって見えますかというと
光が曲がっちゃったんです
光が曲がったことを我々には鉛筆が曲がってると見えるんです
だからいつでもそこは起こるんですよ
無常なのに常住だと認識するんです
その上 価値観 感情なども上書きするんです
花を見て ああ バラの花だと思って
思って終わるんじゃなく
そこもう天道なんですけど
それでなんて綺麗な花で私は好きですよとかね
この黄色いバラなのはものすごい
他の赤いバラ ピンクバラよりはすごい好きですよと
いろいろ価値観まで上乗せするんです
この間違ったことを 花が散る
世界が変わるなどの見解は
真理の立場で見る無常ではありません
これは無常と言ったっても
大体みんな知っていると
えらい転倒しています
特に随分昔 私は日本で無常について語ったところで
これは日本人にはよくわかりやすいんだとかね
まあラジオ局やいろんなとこ行くけど
すごく褒めるんです あんた言うことはね
日本人の感情的にはね
感性ではね ものすごくわかりやすいことをね
我々の文化教えてくれるの
我々の文化ではね それは無常はよくわかる文化だと
同時に私は学者でしたからね
学生でしたからね このテレビ局
ラジオ局の連中にはね
偉そうなこと言えないし
ああ そうですかね それはよく勉強になりましたよと言いながら
何言ってるの この連中かと
無常の考え方はあるわけないでしょう
だからなんとかもう鐘が鳴るとか
なんとかありますね で
理容師のなんだかんだとかね
正義を無常やと歌ってるとかね
あれ 無常じゃなくて なんか感情的な何かか
もうもうもう日本人というのはよくこの別れっていうのが好きですからね
別れて その苦しみがすごい好きですから
まあ週一回ぐらいなんで別れないんですか？離婚してまた結婚してとか
そんなに好きだったら
ただそれ話してるだけなんですよ
というのは 時間を取りすぎですよ
我々は世界が変わってるなと気づくともう何年も経っているんです
花が散るなとわかるためには
もう二日 三日も経っているんです
例えば自分の家で花を生けたりするでしょう
その花 あ これはもう枯れたんだとわかると
大体 1週間ぐらい経っているんですよ
時間取りすぎ 時間取りすぎだから
その間にいっぱい煩悩生まれてるんです
ああ やっぱりきれいなこの花はね
今度はよくかっこよく生けることができたんだとかね
いっぱい煩悩が生まれてるんです
無常を知ると煩悩が消えるはずなんです
無常を知った時点で悟りに達するんです
だから我々は 1年かけて
10年かけて  40年かけて
やっぱり変わるんだと気づいたと
遅すぎ その 40年間もう煩悩いっぱい生まれてるんです
だからそこを世間で皆様方も口癖で言ってる
やっぱり無常やとかね
言ってることは真理の無常じゃないんです
はい 転倒二に行きます
ドゥッケーディッカルースカンティサンガイパーラーソウティッタイパーラーソウディッティパーラーソウ
この あ ここに対してですね
ちょっとこれに対して
苦 良いものであるという概念
天道 心の天道 見解の天道
すべて苦ですけど 生きることも苦なんですよ
なのに楽しいと 世界は良いものであると思っちゃう
そこも天道なんです 一切の現象は苦であり
空しいものであり 良いとするべき価値があるものではないのに
我々には価値がある良いものなのです
我々にとっては世界は価値がある
家族には価値がある 学校には価値がある
まあ自分が集まっているガラクタに価値があるとか
もう何にでも価値があるんですよ
壊れている古いガラクタとか集めて
まあこれ鑑定までしてもらったりして
まあイチローさんが着ていたなんとか Tシャツだよで
これはもう 100万円やとね
じゃあイチローさんの汗の
汗の匂いも入っていますと
だったら 200万円やと
どういうことですか？そんならと言いたくて
私は 例えば記録に達する時のバットとか
どれくらい値段するんですかね
イチローが このまあもうもう安打ですからね
よく打ちますからね それでもうもうそれであの性質というものはね
例えば記録に達しましたと
その記録に達した そのバットなんかはね
何千万値段するんで そんなに高くないんですけど
まあ一応特注して作ってもらうんだから
皆様が使っている野球バットよりはまあまあ五
六倍値段するかもしれませんだけど
それにしても  1本10万円にはなりませんよ
だから我々は何にでも価値が入れたりして
それで苦しんだりしている
それで一番価値を入れるのは自分の命になんですね
人生にすごい価値を入れている
だからすごい人生では苦しむんですね
本当は何でも虚しいんですよ
あんまりどうったことはないんです
それはわからないんですね
はい 天道さんに行きます
アナクタにビッグウェーアンターテサンニャイパーラスチテパラディティバラソー
一切の現象は実体のない無我なのに
我であるという概念 天道は心の天道
見解の天道なんです 何か種みたいな芯みたいなものはどこにもないんです
全部なんか幻 幻覚みたいなもんで
しかし 何かあるんだぞと思っているんです
実体があるんだぞ 自分に
物事に絶対変わらない
霊魂 魂 自我 実体があると勘違いすることです
自分に霊魂があるとか思ったりするでしょうに
実体があると 魂がある
それとかなりのネズミ像
天道です あべこべです
でもあべこべで言うんだから
自分にとってはあべこべだと感じないことがポイントなんです
だからお釈迦様のこと変ではないかと思っちゃうんです
でも自分という気持ちはあるでしょうと
ずっとあるんだ あんた何言うのかと
なんでそんなに自我がない
自我がないと もう突出してるんですかと
それで日本の学者さんは
まあ仏教 ブッダは無我と言ったんですけど
非我だと言ってないんだと
逆ですか？我に表す非我だと言ってますけど
無我だと言ってないんだと
だから我があるんだと
我があるんだったら なんで非我と言うんですかね
それだったら まあとにかく大変な天道なんです
で  4番目 アスレティックウェー
スーパースーパーサンガイパーラスチテパラスディッキーパラス
不浄であるものに対して
浄であるという概念の天道
心の天道 見解の天道です
いつでも 3ステップで天道することです
はい これは自分の肉体に対するアプローチですよ
自分の肉体はすっごい清らかなものだと思っているんです
だから我々はきれい好きで
清潔感ですごいですよ
汚いものは触らないとか
あれやこれやとか 自分自身が何者かとか
汚いそのものなんです
肉体は不浄そのものなんですけど
だからあまりにも熱狂しちゃって
もう清潔感でもう病気になるどころまでいっちゃいますね
自と他の肉体に執着して
最善 最美 最上だと思うと
今置かれている状況から先進はできないんです
まあまあ 強引にこういう単語を作ったんですけど
辞書にはないんで 最美とか最上とかがね
だからちょっとおかしいかもしれませんだけどね
最も美しい 最も清らかということでね
日本語にするならば場所がないんだからね
そこで私たちは 私の体は世界一美しくて
世界一清らかで すごいことやと思っていると
ずっと肉体につかまれたまま先進ないんです
例えば人のことをあなたは世界一美人だ
なんて美しい方だと思ってみてください
その人から逃げられなくなりますよ
もういても立っても寝ていても
その人のことばっかり頭の中で回転するの
それで家中写真持って撮ってきて
家中あちこち貼っておいたりして
大変なことになるんですよ
病気になるんですよ だから実際
お釈迦様はそういう病気になった例まで記録しているんです
体がきれいだと思っておくと
こんなことになるのかと
これ あるお坊さんの話で
インドの美人というか
もうインド まあそのコーセルの国かな
コーセルの国の美人なんですね
で 選ぶんですよ あの女性の中から
で これあんまりにも美しい方で
人々は 1 日彼女と生活するためには銭を払わないといけないんです
それ決まり 法律 しかし
1 日だけ その 1 日では
彼女は料理を作ってあげれば
もう歌ってあげれば 踊ってあげれば何でもしてあげるんです
だから本人は 1 日だけ
この絶世の美人と一緒に生活ですごい喜びを感じる
だからあまりにも喜びを感じたんだから
また苦労して もうもう一回行きたいと思うんです
だから全寮だから 一般人にとってはもう払える値段じゃないんです
だから だからわざとそういうふうに値段設定までしているんです
だから王様やお坊ちゃんたちやら
もう何人かにしか彼女を呼んでお祭りすることはできないんです
そういう人がいて ある人が出家したんですね
仏道の世界に入ったんです
仏道の世界に入ったところで話を聞いたんです
あのセリマというあの節制な美人がブッダの信者さんだよ
あら またびっくり この人は
あの人 あの有名人もブッダのという
仏教徒ですか もう別に他の問題では別にもう一人の人しか何もないんです
ああ セリマさんもまあ時々来ますよ
まああれセリマさんや
これは何々さんやと だってここも来るし
あの今日はここに来たんだから
そういうのは一般的であんまり全然何のこともないんです
ここが来たってお坊さんたちはたちまち立ち上がったりとかね
瞑想をやめて もうそんなの全然ないんです
例えばここが来たっても
迷惑にならないように
もう避けて避けて避けて
お釈迦様のところに行く
仏教の世界はそういう世界なんです
人間は平等です この人は出家してばっかりで
まだまだ成長していないし
もう全くだらしないからだらしないんです
そこでまあ 彼女はお釈迦様がいる間で
彼女と他の金持ちの人々は当番でお釈迦様のお布施をしているんですと
比丘たちの だからたくさんのお坊さんたちがいるんだから
それで彼女も毎日お布施しているんです
で 何人かに だから人 人いるんだから
彼女に例えば人行くかもしれません
それは一応あるお坊さんがいます
職人というか 仕事を与えているお坊さんがいて
そのお坊さんが決めるんです
この人はあちらに行きなさい
この人はあの家に来なさいと
この人はあちらの家に来なさいとか
この認定されているお坊さんが決めるんです
そのお坊さんに逆らってはいけないんです
もう戒律で決めてるんで
戒律であるお坊さんが
この食事のお坊さんたちを分配する
職でそろそうと決めたら
その人の判断は判断で逆らうことはできないんです
言われたところに行くしかないんです
そこで そのお坊さんも
それは平等に均等にやらなくちゃいけないと
個人的な好みでやってはいけないし
人の顔を見てやってはいけないし
例えばサーリプッタさんが来てほしいというならば
みんな一斉にうちのうちのうちのと言うでしょうに
そうするとサーリプッタさんじゃ
左側一日一か所にしか行けないんだから
そうなってくると 再婚の人々の間でもものすごい争いが起こるんです
私はもう気持ち悪いやとかね
私はサーリプッタさんに食品のオフィスなかったんだけどとか文句言っちゃうと
これたまったものじゃない
だからそれは再婚でも禁止と
あまり禁止ではないんだけど
まあ空いていれば要求は聞いてあげます
空いてなかったらどうしようもないということ
で だから昔のお坊たちはあんまり個人的に接待を受けるということをあまり遠慮するんです
サンガにあの注文出してくださいと
で サンガが決めて誰が行くでしょうと
その方が一応安全 それでそういう認定されたお坊さんも一応くじを引くんですよ
毎日 毎日何か書いておいたら
お坊さんたちはそれをくじを取っちゃうんです
取ったらそちらに誰の家かと書いてます
どんなグループかとか
そこで そのくじで決めた人人はその家に行くしかもう誰にも言うことはできないんです
それであの人にくじが当たったんですよ
セリマさんの家に 悪いことに
これで次の日からもうもうもう夜も考えてて
もうなんとも思ったことやと
ただで見られますから
このすごい人は でもその時は彼女はそんなに若くはなかった
年取っていたんで すごい老人ではなくて
一応女性の年ってそんなに長持ちしませんだからね
気分だけですね 歳の人も歳と思っているのは
歳ぐらいで全部終わりですけど
私は知ったことはないんですけど
で で 彼女もまあまあ そんなに元気でみんな喜ばせる年ではなかったし
まあ一応仏教の信者さんになってからは
まあそこら辺で忙しくて
もうお布施することやら瞑想することやらね
もうまだ金持ちでしょうしね
もう 1日誰かに全量どうでもいいんだ
そんなことは だからこのまあ
で このお坊さんがお布施にいただきに家に行った時は
彼女発作を起こしたんですね
発作を起こしちゃって
体がだから発作を起こすということは
もういきなり目を大変なことになりますから
目が変なところに行っちゃうわ
口が曲げるわ よだれが出るわ
もう体が震えているわ
大変なんです だから何の美しさも何も残らない
発作を起こして倒れちゃったんです
倒れても彼女はお布施だけちゃんと使いに頼んでやらせているんです
料理は彼女は作りませんだから
それで時間になってきたら
彼女はいくらなんでもお坊さんたちに礼をしなくちゃ
毎日やってるんだから
だから私をお坊さんたちのところに運びなさい
運びなさいと 言うと みんなこのボロボロになってる彼女をなんとかしてお坊さんたちが托鉢に来たところに運んで持って行ったんです
運んで持っていったら
彼女はすごく手両手震えるなり
震える手でもう礼をして
で それでまたもうさっさとこんなところにいられませんだから
他の寺院の人々はまた家の中に運んで寝かしておいたんです
で 彼女は発作で亡くなったんです
その日 だから普通のちょっとした痙攣じゃないんです
おそらく心臓発作を起こしたでしょう
あるいは脳出血とかなんとかどうかね
書いてないんです このお坊さんが見たのは
もうボロボロ 醜くなった瞬間なんです
セリマさんの人生の一番かっこ悪い時なんです
見たのは 最悪の姿を見たんです
この最悪の姿を見ても
メスだけは達人だから
今 最悪の姿で一番醜い姿でいたっても
この方は相当美人だと
相当この体格 この色とかね
元気な時ってどんなことでしょうかと
思っちゃいます 本人が見たのは一番もう最悪
最低 もう一番体形悪い時なんです
何の見栄もひとかけらもできないと
なのに それでもすごい美人だと
それでそのお坊さん病気になっちゃったんです
そのまま家にお寺に帰って
ご飯も食べないでそのまま寝込んじゃったんです
だからそれでもお釈迦様
これは相当なショック与えないと治らないと
この人は お坊さんたちはいろんなこと言うんでご飯食べない
で お釈迦様は放っておけと
言って国王にメッセージを送ったんです
彼女の死体を 国の財産ですよ
彼女はとにかく だから国葬なんです
あの葬式やめなさい 中止と
お釈迦様に言われたら
すぐ国王も困ったなとやめたんです
それで遺体はそのまま放っておきなさい
ブッダが言われるもんだからね
現代人と違ってね 昔はね
国王であっても政府であっても
お釈迦様に言われたらやらないといけないということで
それで放っておいたんです
お釈迦様はまだ連絡も行かないんですね
じゃあいいんでしょうと
それで 1 週間が経っちゃったんです
遺体はめちゃめちゃ腐ったんです
膨らんじゃって 膿が出て
ものすごいひどい臭いが出始めたんです
で ちょうど 1 週間も経って腐ってる時
お釈迦様がでは葬式やりましょうと
私も来ますよ 私だけじゃなくて
みんな町の人々 彼女の知ってる人々みんな集めてください
で 王様に言うんだから
王の命令でみんな集めたんです
お釈迦様は比丘たちと一緒にどうと葬式に行くんです
それでお釈迦様がアナンガ尊者にね
あの比丘の皆さん 一緒に行きましょうと
ずっとアナンが お釈迦様
あなたにもね 一緒に行きなさいと葬式に言ったと
ああ そうですかと セリマさんの葬式ですか
じゃあ行く行くと もう 1 週間も倒れてたのをやんなくもなく
さっさと行ったんです
行ってももうお坊さんのランクでもう最下位だから
お釈迦様はメッセージを送っただけで
おそらく顔を見ることもないでしょう
見られることもないでしょう
後ろにいるだけです お釈迦様と王様がもう
対話するんです 彼女は若い時
1 日どれぐらい料金取っていたのかといったら
1 日千両ですよ では これはもう全部競り出してください
千両で買って持って行ってくださいと
そうするとずっともらえますから
前は 1 日だけですからね
かなり儲かりますからね
王様に競り出して競り出してください
ここもお釈迦様が言う通りに
職人さんに頼んで頼んで競り出すんです
遺体を ではっきり言うね
彼女は前はね 千両払ったらたった 1 日だけですから
今度はもう権利書を全部与えますよ
千両で買いたい人は誰でしょうかと
金持ちはいっぱいいた
誰も手を挙げないんですね
お釈迦様 なんともなんか売れないみたいね
じゃあ値段下げて 高そう機関を値段下げてもらうんです
値段下げて出しても誰も注文出しないんです
出さない そうすると 1両になっちゃったんです
でお釈迦様は 1両でもお釈迦様の声には特色がありまして
お釈迦様が言うことは大体みんなに聞こえるんです
こういう機械はいらないんです
それは特別な能力で 説法を聞く気持ちも何ともない人には聞こえない
届かない 例えば中に入らなくて遠く来ている人がいて
とにかくぜひ説法を聞きたいと思うならば
なんだかとなく自分の耳元で話しているように聞こえるのです
だからみんなに聞きたいものには聞こえる
時々いろんな変な思考で自分を売り込みたくて
いつでも自分を出す人々がいて
出家の中でも真っ直ぐ前に座るんですね
ブッダの真理理解しよう
欲を飲む気持ちじゃないんです
私は先で私は先やっていること
何も聞こえない あの性格直らない限りはダメなんです
一番前に座った はっきり言うの
それの私の前に座ったって意味がないんで
もう何十も遠いだよ それでお釈迦様が言うことをみんなに聞こえるんです
王様が言うことは聞こえないから
王様はそこで声のある専門家頼むんです
でお釈迦様がなんか 1円でも売れないねと
じゃあ誰かに欲しい人に食べてあげてください
というので そうすると
ではただでもらう人はどなたがいるんでしょうかと
最後に誰も手を挙げませんね
でお釈迦様はそれで誰もいない
誰もいないでしょうと
だってそんなもんだよ
この身体が これに執着するのは愚か者以外誰も執着しませんよと
この肉体は不浄なものであると
愚か者はすごい価値があるんだとしたっても
その様だよ で 厳しく説法して
では正直しなさいと で
葬式参加して帰ったんです
お坊さんが病気治りまして
悟りに出したんです だからまあこれ危ないんですよ
だから体肉体はなんて綺麗ですかと思っちゃうと
どうなることかと だから初めからも心は熱僧の専門家だから
そういうこと起こるんですよ
だからこの 4番目の天道っていうのは
肉体はやっぱりありのままに見てくださいと
ありのままに見ると本当に気持ち悪くなるんです
例えば自分の食卓で もうものすごいごちそうを用意して
人の人間の生首もどこかに置いておけば食べられますかね
別にご飯の上に置くわけじゃないんですよ
食卓のどこかで人の生首見たことないですよ
だからもう気持ち悪さはわからないだけ
何としてでも そういう人を死んだ人の体の部品とか見た方がいいんですよ
本物で いかに気持ち悪いものか
だから体に対して不浄ですから
浄だと思うことは良くない天道だと教えているんです
自と他の体も 他のものの物ものを物質として観察する場合もあります
そこで私の体 人の体ではなくて
全部物質だよとこう観察瞑想するときもあります
その時は浄不浄の立場を使用しない
その時 汚い 汚いと思わないんです
ただの物質だ 体体と思う場合は
不浄観の瞑想をしなくちゃいけない
物質だと理解する人にとっては不浄観ではないんです
ただの物質として見てください
世界は肉体至上主義です
世界の哲学はたった一つ決まってます
肉体至上主義なんです
一切の努力 能力 肉体の維持管理するためのものです
私たちは何のどんな努力したっても
ただの肉体のために 肉体の維持管理のためにやっているんです
しかし 肉体は老いて病に倒れて
一切の期待努力を無にして裏切って壊れるものだと理解もしないんです
人類が肉体のために一切かけて頑張ってますけど
肉体には確実に裏切りますよ
確実に裏切るのに知ろうともしないんです
考えるともしないです
この体に裏切られるんだよとではなくて
まあまあ一番高価な大トロはどうやって食べるのかと
頭はそれなんです この間話聞いたことありますけど
世界は悪人ばっかしで
我々には鯨の肉もステーキも食べることはできなくなったと
手に入らないぐらい高くなったと泣いてる人もいたんです
まあ飢えているでしょ
今死んでるでしょうね
飢えて まあとにかく 我々は肉体主義をすることで食べ物はいくらでもあるでしょうに
クジラが食えなくなったら他のものを食べればいいでしょうに
やっぱり肉体のためにどんな残酷なことでもして肉体の維持管理をする
美味しく食べるために牛をむちゃくちゃ
なんて言いますか 苦労させる
もうビールまで酒まで飲ませたりして
歩いちゃうと走っちゃうと筋肉硬くなるんだからね
霜降りにならないんだから
脂肪いっぱいないと だから歩かせないし
動かせないし どこかで聞いた話なんですけど
この丸焼きにする場合はね
豚とかもう このあの生きたままでまずぐちゃぐちゃ殴るんだそうです
肉を死んでから叩いてもグニャグニャにならないんだ
だから生きてるまんまでもういっぱい殴って殴って
このもう だから血液が血管が腫れてあちこちに流れていって
この筋肉が膨らんで柔らかくなる
それで豚っていうのは人間より痛いんですよ
この神経は 耐えられないんです
そこで殴って殴って殴って
それなりに道具があってね
ポンポンポンポンとものすごく痛くなるように腫れるように
殴って この 3 日間ぐらいそこを続けてやって
それから殺して そのまま丸焼きにすると
どれぐらい残酷 それからまたどこかで
この鶏とかは簡単に死んじゃいますから
殺しちゃうと冷凍しなくちゃいけないんですね
冷凍しちゃうとちょっとお金がかかったりするし
まあ自然に優しくないんだことで
一応処分する鶏たちというのは
くちばしとか全部切っちゃって
そのまま箱 いろいろ入れ物に箱に入れて
そのまま置いておくんだって
そうするとまだまだ生きているんだから
それで適当に殺して殺してマーケットに置くんだ
そういう食うことだけ考えて
命のことをまるっきり考えないでやっているということは
もうかなりあります だからこの私は何が言いたいかって
そこまでやっても肉体には裏切りますよと
それはなんで理解しないんですかね
体のために生きていると
必ず体に裏切ります